- [Gary] Fuck!
(triumphant rock music)
What if I told you
this was the last
Monday morning of your life?
- Alright, heading
to the Jets game.
Avi is here.
Looking for my crew.
Ready to head to the stadium.
("Inspire" by Pitthakid)
Alright, I need predictions.
Nate, what do you got today?
- 27-10 Patriots.
- [Gary] Phil?
- That feels right to me.
- They flex it again, we
don't even have the game.
- [Gary] They push it?
- Mhmmm.
- [Gary] What do you got though?
- I have 41-5 Patriots.
- [Gary] Oooph.
Alex isn't here, he's finished.
- Wow.
(group laughter)
- Are we live right now?
- [Gary] Yeah, no, I'm not live.
I'm filming my DailyVee.
- [AJ] You do your
own filming now?
- [Gary] I'm DRock now.
- [AJ] 'Cause
DRock's in Asia, right?
- [Gary] Yeah.
Now that I'm doing it
seven days a week,--
- [AJ] You have to
do some sometimes.
- [Gary] I have to do sometimes.
- [AJ] Weird.
What's up?
- [Gary] How we feeling
about this season?
- Terrible.
- The season's terrible.
- It's shit.
Straight shit.
- Terrible.
- [Gary] The level of
hate I have for these
Patriot fans is enormous.
Like, I hate that dude.
I hate that Gronk
kid right there.
I hate you.
These fucking characters.
Even though the Jets suck, the
one great thing for me on this,
and I think we all
need it, is escapism.
What the Jets do for me is allow
me not to care about anything
during those
three or four hours.
I'm just zoned into the Jets
and if the internet and alcohol
became illegal in
America, I wouldn't care.
I'd deal with it afterwards.
I think all of us need to find
our escapism and we need to
balance how much escapism we
need based on our ambition.
That's how we do it.
That's why I love it.
Uh-oh, what up, Vern?
- What up, man?
- Uh-oh, we're here.
- [Vernon] We're here.
- We're here.
Alright, Nate, today
we trust you the most.
We're gonna have
you start it off.
- 27-10 Patriots,
they score on the opening
drive is the key play.
- [Gary] What do you got?
- 37-18 Patriots.
- [Gary] Key play?
- Brady to Mitchell,
50-yard touchdown.
- That's my thoughts,
Mitchell two touchdowns,
31-21.
- [Gary] Okay.
Vernon?
- Come on Vernon.
- [Gary] You had a big
score in the car, stick with it.
- 35-10, Patriots.
- [Gary] Key play?
- Key play?
Pick 6 by Butler.
- [Gary] Wow.
- 21-17 Jets, Brandon
Marshall has a big day,
two touchdowns.
- 41-12 Patriots.
We got to 12 with a
safety by the way,
we didn't kick four field goals.
(group laughter)
Key play, Edelman breaks six
tackles on the opening drive for
a 41-yard touchdown
and spirits are broken.
- Say it ain't so.
I got 20-17 Jets.
Got a Nick Folk
field goal for the win.
- 23-20 Jets.
- [AJ] Wow!
- Quincy Enunwa,
16 catches for 409.
(group laughter and crosstalk)
- Every game I've
rooted against the Jets.
Today, I'm going Jets 17-10.
Which means I'll lose again,--
- Yeah.
- key play of the game
six minutes and 47 seconds
into the third
quarter Tom Brady goes
down with an ACL.
- Killers, killers man.
- Little Lou?
- 10-6 Jets, Gostkowski missed
field goal in the fourth quarter
leads to a game winning
field goal from Folk.
- [Gary] Love it.
- [AJ] Selfie time.
- 23-20 Jets.
Robby Anderson.
- 41-5 Patriots,
six minutes and 50 seconds
into the third quarter.
- [Man] 39-12 the Patriots.
- Makes sense.
(group laughter)
Yeah, whatever.
- [All] And the
home of the Jets!
- Walking in.
I'm not excited.
Little Lou feels terrible.
- [AJ] Bad news.
- Bad news.
Don't let the Jets
beat you Patriot fans.
I'll fucking go on
a Twitter rampage.
("Poppies" by KNGDAVID)
- [Gary] The club.
Coaches Club, baby.
Phil, you fancy.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Here we got food,
to get some free water.
Let's see what's going on.
Sush, sush, sush.
Alright, let's go where
we're really going.
Let's see, see, see.
Yep, this is my
home away from home.
Alright, walk up.
I make this walk
10 times a year.
I hate that little
kid on the right.
I hate that little kid.
(crowd booing)
You pieces of shit.
Fuck you!
He got him.
- [AJ] Horrible spot.
He gave it to him.
(crowd unrestful)
- Fuck!
- [Referee] The ruling on
the field has been changed.
(crowd cheering)
(fireworks exploding)
Touchdown!
To me!
To me, Woody!
Reading the comments
from the last DailyVee.
The buyer always pays,
always pays the shipping.
(toilet flushes)
("Poppies" by KNGDAVID)
We lost.
(bell dings)